we are live here with the cast from Star
Trek discovery and here's the thing when
this whole adventure began I remember
they were like oh we're gonna gamble
we're gonna have our main character this
is an American woman and hopefully
everything works out and now look at
your season three just announced what is
it what does it mean I mean I can't even
express what it would it means to me you
know we have so many elements of
diversity on our show
and you know we're trying to push that
needle forward and keep it keep up with
the essence of what Star Trek is but
just being a black woman at the helm of
it and hearing from young girls
especially um it makes me cry and I just
thank God and you now have season three
that was just announced right whoa
season three and what can you expect can
you give us any ideas or and it were we
going well then comes III come and join
us I'm playing a Cleveland Booker book
short there you go and he's a man on a
personal mission who bumps into Vernon
yeah is she a friend is she a foe we'll
we'll find out I guess and it's
incredible because of course we're
almost a thousand years into the future
right so we are boldly going where no
one has gone before literally and it's
very very exciting and exhilarating
because we get to build this new world
who are we now where are we and now who
are we so it's exciting and we've we've
built on these two you know and we still
have our connection to Canada from the
enterprise exact behind when they went
into the true it did it did I want to
ask you cuz Star Trek really is one of
the legacy shows of comic-con when you
walk out there you will the one thing
you always find is Trekkies what's it
like and what your comic-con experienced
bit like it's your first it's my very
first San Diego comic-con so it's wild I
mean it's just so surreal and to be like
injected into this world and plugged
into this fan base is just something I
never could have imagined
you know it's yeah it's wild yeah the
love is intoxicating
because there's so much 11 positivity
and then obviously you know Star Trek
represents such beautiful things yeah
such a beautiful truths and so to be a
part of it to represent it it's an honor
and we just sort of like we feel kind of
faint from all the love well there's
also so much focus on everything like
cheering and miss a beat thank you can't
miss a beat because there's somebody out
there who will tell you actually that
guy you know and Ethan so Ethan plays
Spock I play number one from the
original enterprise series and you know
to be stepping in someone else's shoes
also we stay very near and dear to the
Canon but we have to really honor these
characters while taking artistic
liberties at the same time it's
terrifying and we care so much you know
wait a minute did somebody say to you
today what do you mean what you're
saying oh you're saying oh oh really
it's just in terms of respecting Canon
he was throwing up a Vulcan salute and
and I had to give him a little
adjustments all right and I was oh gotta
look out gotta look out that was so
close that was Mitch me backstage before
we went onstage oh wow I got it wrong in
a decent game scream that would that
would change everything so close people
care um can I ask you about Space Jam
yes oh yeah mrs. IP LeBrons wife yeah
way ahead we're live now well you're
looking back and you're worried your
folks like oh all right just tell me
what can you tell us oh gosh what can I
tell you I don't think I can tell you
anything um it's cool it's amazing was
one of my favorite films growing up and
oh you know that's not what I think you
didn't fall for that
uh uh you know Space Jam space is like
Star Trek so there's usually no right
I'm very excited I'm very excited I feel
very much ok it sounds like it's gonna
be amazing
by the way real quick you guys is there
a guest star that you want to bring in
that you would love to have on the show
that's a really good question
really so many people I'm hoping there's
a discovery card crossover I would love
that
I think we all want that right just
listen let's make that happen
it is Jerry more of housewives of Star
Trek guy
Star Trek these days yeah it better be
Star Trek you'd better be organelles
right or house it just will not work you
guys congratulations thank you so much
thank you and you know what if there's
any secret you want to tell this live
audience mm-hmm
any secret you want to tell there for
sure let's go yeah let's tell em
everything yeah it's gonna be a Space
Jam Star Trek we got and we finally got
it make sure you check it out yeah thank
you thank you thank you very much
you